yes because my best self kamila Kibeho
is calling out body shamers and sending
an inspiring message to her fans I think
I've been just I feel like I'm just
gotten to know myself really well this
year in a lengthy insta story post
kamila says she's been avoiding social
media with the conscious intention of
avoiding things that would hurt her
feelings but while logging on to
celebrate the two-year anniversary of
her hit song Havana she came across a
headline about being body shamed
honestly first thing I felt was super
insecure just imagining what these
pictures must look like oh no my
cellulite oh no I didn't suck in my
stomach but then I was like of course
there are bad pictures of course there
are bad angles my body's not made of
rock or muscle for that matter I feel
like I just feel really I just feel
really like appreciative of being able
to like live and I feel like I just know
what's important in life
right now so I'm just I'm really happy
and I feel very I don't I feel like
really in touch with my emotions
the singer goes on to express her
heartbreak at the thought of young
people growing up in an airbrushed world
and seeking a perfection that's not real
girls cellulite is normal fat is normal
it's beautiful and natural I won't buy
into the bull day not today Satan and I
hope you don't either
[Music]
of course a lot of recent headlines
about Camila have focused on her
relationship status with senorita
collaborator Shawn Mendes a source
previously told ET the two have really
fallen for one another and are committed
to working on a relationship